let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud and do not give a [ __ ]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [ __ ] them
welcome everybody this is the Tony
Michaels and this is Gabe Sanchez and we
put together the best of the week from
the Tony Michaels podcast don't go
anywhere and stay right here for the
best of the week I want to bring in
someone who uh who who has some
experience with with the the Christian
uh right as it were
um Ron Reagan and I also want to bring
in David Bender as well Ron how are you
how are you Ron ciao from Italy yes yes
yes yes yes how's how's the wood cutting
going I know
that's a lot of wood that's a lot of
wood David how are you today I'm just
throwing my hat in the ring yeah I I see
I see everyone's uh got their hats on
today this is not a uh Sombrero okay
good trilby hat okay just to be clear it
goes back to the old world did you
forget wash your hair today you know
it's it's been that kind of day I will
wash my hair so long as Donald Trump's
name is spoken aloud it's been a long
time
so so Ron Ron Ron what do you make of
what Texas ball was talking about here
because the Oath Keepers and the proud
boys they're not really uh part of the
Christian nationalist movement as much
as they've adopted it to try to you know
Stoke violence in the country it seems I
think a lot of the things that he was
saying are very important uh and that
that in in particular there is a whole
now Christian white nationalist
dominionist movement which is being
absorbed into the larger Republican
party which is anti-democratic and this
you know you listen to Doug mastriani in
Pennsylvania and and a bunch of others
now and they're openly talking about not
only violence
but really the fact that um white
Christian nationalists are the only
people who should be in charge of
anything in our country and everybody
else who doesn't buy into their cult
um has no place in our government no
place in our media no place running
businesses and uh and they're going to
to work hard to make sure that that
comes true and they're not against using
violence as he pointed out yes you know
The Oath Keepers and the proud boys
these people to drop dress up as
bumblebees and stuff yeah they're
wannabes and their clan
um not that they're not dangerous but
they're clowns but he mentioned the
praetorian guard and there are others
like them who are serious people who've
got real military training and they mean
to put it to use and those some of those
people are still in the military and
still in law enforcement and they're not
leaving they're going to be embedded
there and these people pose a real
danger to our country well you know
another group named Adam Waffen we've we
saw that name appear several months ago
when the Department of Justice was
really tracking down some of the threats
that were made on nuclear power plants
some electrical plants uh around the
country that's another Neo-Nazi type
group that is you know totally in line
with trumpism as it were so David give
us your take I I actually have a
question for Ron because this is
something that's concerned me for a
while now
uh we're seeing that possibly uh Tony
honorado a member of the Secret Service
who became a political uh appointee in
the Trump White House and then what is
now back with the Secret Service yeah is
it possible you you experienced the
Secret Service I I this is something
that has concerned me with active duty
military active duty law enforcement
and even worse and more dangerously
active duty Secret Service that may buy
into some of this how does one address
that how do you how do you find out what
people are thinking
in in these uh active duty roles that
they play
that's a very good question and uh this
is a very difficult thing to do you
don't want to be in the position
necessarily of purging people from
government because you think they may
disagree with you politically that's the
sort of thing that Donald Trump would do
on the other hand I I can say that if
you're in the Secret Service or any
other branch of government and you are a
trumpist if you are a stop the steel
person you are not a fan of our our
democracy anymore you are not defending
the Constitution
um and as such as a person like that you
ought not to be in those positions
anymore if I was the head of the Secret
Service I would begin quietly inquiring
about people who were with the pbd the
presidential productive detail who Trump
uh my you know what I've heard is
selected because they were loyalists to
him not the Office of the President and
I would begin moving them out or at
least moving them out to distant uh
distant posts maybe in Alaska which is
where honorado is now he's moved out
he's not been disengaged but I I think
this is something that you know going
forward and and I I commend to everyone
and I put it up in our chat here but to
everyone listening there's a piece that
Greg Sargent has in the Washington post
about how uh this violent movement that
we're going to be talking about today
the hearings will be showing is uh a an
early warning sign around the world when
you begin to see democracies falling and
what uh Sergeant's piece does is through
experts racial client teller I think
he's written a book about it talks about
exactly that the people who are in
government the people are outside of it
but who are willing to use violent
tactics and this is the fear that the
violence hasn't stopped at all with
January 6th it's going to be going on
and obviously some of the things that we
just saw the Supreme Court do has has
been more uh incendiary uh than anything
in my memory to polarize the nation so I
I it is it's a concern at so many levels
how do Ron you're absolutely right you
can't do Purity tests but I do think and
and we heard this the oath that you take
is to the Constitution not to a person
when James Comey walked into that office
and was asked or sat down and said you
know I expect loyalty from you
he meant to a person not the office not
the Constitution so this is we've we saw
this play out but we haven't seen it
over it's not over at all Donald Trump
is the now the symptom he is not the
disease no no that's right and you know
you mentioned Mr uh chipolone which is
the as close as I can come to the actual
Italian pronunciation
is his actual name Mr chipolone Mr
Chipotle is no cure here Mr cipolloni is
a bad guy uh he has seen it in his own
best interest I suspect because he
doesn't want to lose his law license to
cooperate to some extent with the with
the committee Mr Chipotle claiming
attorney-client privilege who was his
client not Mr Trump the White House the
executive branch and that means us so
he's he's got that all wrong
um and I'm surprised they let him get
away with that but I think they really
wanted to hear what he had to say about
certain things and were willing to to
play ball with him to a certain extent
um but you know you mentioned the
Supreme Court
um we've got three branches of
government
the Judiciary we've got the legislative
and we have the executive and then we
have a fourth estate which is of course
the price the media but uh the Judiciary
branch is already gone
it is now utterly corrupt and without
any legitimacy six religious fanatics on
the on the Supreme Court are going to do
whatever they want to do uh there
they've pretty much announced that uh
the legislative branch the Senate of
course is profoundly undemocratic the
way it's constituted and uh and can get
nothing done if Democrats lose the house
uh in November and the entire
legislative branch then is effectively
under the control of Republicans well
that just leaves the executive
and what happens in 2024 if that falls
to the Republicans too the people that
we're worried about here the people who
have uh who have enabled violence let's
say will now be in charge of our
government and our government as we like
to think of it as a republican democracy
small our Republican democracy will
cease to exist
can I can I why I was going to say uh I
think I think you make a good point
there that there's a lot at stake with
these hearings as we watch uh the
hearing room here the witnesses have not
come in yet
um David I'll give you a chance I want
to bring in my executive producer and
co-host uh Gabe Sanchez hey Gabe hey
there Gabe
so the the only little ring of sunshine
I like to I like to do that uh the you
know uh Rachel used to call me Pollyanna
uh but you know there is a chance Ron if
on the flip side of this if the Senate
expands outside of the Mansion Cinema
blockade
and you get enough votes to overturn the
filibuster and if this is a wave
election not the way we see it but Roe
and these hearings affect Democratic
turnout at a level that may be
unprecedented because people are
genuinely angry about what's happening
he's not simmering down at all it won't
bite October November we hold the house
we have a filibuster uh proof Senate
the bill number one
is to uh make the court what it was when
it became nine justices that was to that
was in Peril to the number of circuit
courts we had you know 150 years ago
there were nine circuit courts nine
Supreme Court Justices
and how many we have now
wait for it 13.
uh counting the federal court of appeals
13 appellate uh
uh courts which allow for
for more justices
that is a game changer and that is not
packing the court that is making the
court equal to the workload and the
burden uh that is what brought it to
nine well when it was changed so that's
me being Pollyanna
um
so we all know that okay but it's
important to say that there is some hope
and there's a reason for people to not
give up and to be prepared to vote in
numbers like no one has ever seen before
in October and November
you know what one other thing that
strikes me about this and I felt the
same way about the Mueller report uh you
know when it came out and before it came
out is we all know what happened
here on January 6th and before and after
we know what the story is it's great
that they're laying it out for an
American public that doesn't maybe pay
quite as much attention as we do it's
great that they're laying that out for
the justice department in case they
really want to pursue legal cases
against everybody including uh Mr Trump
but we all know what happened here a
sitting president tried to interfere
with the peaceful transfer of power
tried to overthrow the government
basically this has never happened before
and it's an extraordinary event and
there it is it's right in front of us
there's no question about this anymore
and there never was but we have to ask
ourselves now what are we really doing
about this as an American public why did
we let this man get into the White House
in the first place well the public
didn't because of course they voted him
you know by three million votes they
gave it to Hillary Clinton but we have
an electoral college what are we going
to do about that
um you know what is wrong with us and
what is wrong with the media that
allowed that to happen it didn't report
honestly on who Donald Trump was from
the very beginning and point out to the
public that it's unacceptable that
somebody like this should end up in the
White House what how are they going to
handle these hearings are they gonna are
they gonna tell us honestly tell the
public honestly what the danger really
is and how severe it is and how imminent
that danger is I hope so Sunday summer
did a good job
you're stirring with the big paddle as
usual well you know a lot of people gave
a lot of criticism to a certain someone
who is on NBC on on Sundays when he made
the statement about uh that it would be
bad for the country if Donald Trump
would face prosecution which I think a
big majority of the country did not
appreciate that statement because I
think the what you're to what you guys
are saying about the Supreme Court all
the branches that government at how we
have elections in this country I believe
actually a prosecution of Donald Trump
is exactly what our country needs at
this point and I think that's what the
January 6th select committee is trying
to do in the in the court of public
opinion because there is going to be
Criminal Courts here we've seen the
criminal courts but the report of public
opinion is the one that I think that
they're operating in with the January
6th elec committee Gabe do you have a
question for our guest here no I just
wanted to add on to what Ron was saying
I think that you make a very good point
it's I mean like you look at kind of
what's happening right we have a coup in
plain sight we literally watch this
happen in real time like the [ __ ]
hitting the fan uh you know with the
Mueller report it was more behind the
scenes and then there was kind of you
know it wasn't until the report was
released and kind of what their findings
were and then at that point people could
dismiss and say oh this wasn't really a
thing or uh you know it was fake news or
was a hoax uh this is different right
and also we are literally watching this
again in real time
with the findings to say we have people
coming forward we have depositions
witness you know Witnesses testifying
under oath we've got documentation
evidence
uh from here to Kingdom Come kind of
right now because like keeps coming and
thanks to people like Cassidy Hutchinson
it allows us to see more people willing
to come forward and and do what you know
more or less they're kind of their right
is or or just the responsibility of
someone who is part of the
administration who at that time kind of
let it happen but now whether through
peer pressure or uh having an epiphany
or what have you are now willing to say
okay
we can't let something like this happen
again and I at least want to be someone
who
puts themselves forward in history as
you know as a person who who's willing
to who is willing to
you know defend democracy defend the
Constitution uh uh uh at least be known
as someone who is willing to say
something as opposed to someone who uh
was gonna be you know dragged through
the mud of history as someone who just
stood by as complacent right
um
yeah our country is at stake here the
Republicans cannot be allowed to take
power again they cannot be allowed to do
that and we're the only people that can
stop that from happening if they take
power again we don't have a democracy
anymore and they've made that very plain
exactly they're not hiding that fact
anymore uh so so like Maya Angelou I
think it was said when somebody tells
you who they are believe them well
they're telling us who they are believe
them it's like someone may speak I'm
going to bring in Harry Littman while
we're waiting here to see if we have
um any speakers here Harry how are you
nice for you to join us I'm I'm happy to
but but who are we waiting for I'm glad
can fill in for you but well I'm not I'm
not sure the main event that you that
you want me to be there is there is no
main event here sometimes Jamie Raskin
makes his way
sometimes he makes his way to the
microphone
um so I keep a close eye on the
microphone here see I I do every I'm the
host and I'm I'm watching the thing and
I'm bringing in the guests but I
appreciate you you joining us here so
what is your first take on the hearing
from today
you know I'm again
Blown Away they they have managed at
each time to up the ante we've kind of
mocked them a little because I guess
they had some professional Consulting
help but man oh man how were they going
to top Cassidy Hutchinson and they did
so I thought they really brought home a
plausible account of just how we got
from the malevolent mind of Donald Trump
to to the melee at the Capitol and
people being killed they you know Drew
at least a dotted line and filled a lot
of it uh in made it understandable
really sort of tore back the curtain and
showed us exactly who was in charge and
what they were doing during those
pivotal days and I find myself as I've
been after many of the hearings kind of
Thunderstruck
well you know you really called the uh
testimony of Cassidy Hutchison such an
uh way well in advance before anyone of
what what what would happen after she
would testify
um and you were absolutely correct there
because we've seen some of these
dominoes fall not just Mark Meadows but
now we've seen Patrick baloney uh
sitting before them and it appears at
the end of the hearing when Liz Cheney
doesn't only accuse Donald Trump of
crimes of tampering with Witnesses but
she also alludes to the fact that we're
gonna hear a lot more from Patsy baloney
in next week's hearing yeah it's gonna
be Tuesday I don't know if it's going to
be Tuesday or Thursday but everyone go
ahead and subscribe to the minus touch
Network right here on YouTube
Tony just on that big I have no idea but
it would it would be a little bit in
character if the person that he called
that he's calling and trying to you know
actually intimidate is Sarah Matthews
who's a bit of a Cassidy Hutchinson type
she quits January 6 from C she was the
deputy press secretary sat pretty close
to all the proceedings uh and uh she's
you know someone if he tried to brow
beat uh her it will I think backfire
it's just going to be a very effective
witness sorry go ahead no no I I think
that's um I think that's exactly right
um we thought she was going to appear
today but they kind of switched it
around on us that's right they've been
very elusive about these hearings and
where they're going with them where
they're not and I don't know what day
we'll get next week but again everyone
stay tuned follow Midas Touch on Twitter
I know you've done some great videos for
my dispatch again the one where you uh
very well called Cassie Hutchison as the
key witness here and again the dominoes
fell so having looking back on that
video that you made about Cassidy yeah
because I think I think her testimony
has seen those dominoes fall but what do
you expect going forward do you think we
have more than eight hearings do you
think they continue this because of the
because of more evidence pouring in of
people maybe protecting themselves with
criminal liability you're the attorney
you tell me yeah well so the next one
was designed to be kind of the
culminating set piece that's how Trump
spent these 184 minutes while the riot
raged he's he's anywhere from you know
jubilant to to uh contemptuous of of the
people who are cowering and you know
worried about being killed as some
people uh were I think we have at least
after that estimation hearing but maybe
one other as well by all accounts
information is flooding into them but I
today's hearing just went so so close
home we you know I'd heard well
everything happened in this December
18th meeting and it seemed like really
you're going to tie it all to that but
this was not in your normal meaning six
hours of people screaming at each other
and you know look here's my basic
feeling Tony about today there are the
there are ragtag
conspiracy theorists in the world there
are you know half-lives and and and low
lives uh in the world
um and that and we saw them here today
but they but what happened is everybody
and this wasn't clear before the
hearings every grown-up in the room told
Trump there's nothing to be done here so
he just cast about until he could find
and look at this look at this crew of
Scoundrels Powell Flynn Giuliani and
then Stuart Rhodes and he and the
hearing today made a really conclusive
show and that these were the people he
summoned these were the people actually
exercising Presidential Power for
um you know two three very pivotal days
and these were the people who really
endangered the life of his vice
president so they were it was almost
like a a you know crazy picaresque novel
or something but then you just had to
remember there they're they're here and
playing a role on the stage because
Trump at his Wit's End and and out of
options has empowered them to do it I've
prosecuted guys like this they're around
but that they should be uh ex you know
doing the bidding of the president of
the United States that's the remarkable
point of this story and that means it
really does go back to Donald Trump well
it was it's a very weird American
history story that that people are
walking into a meeting where the
president's sitting with the CEO or the
former CEO of Overstock trying to figure
out how to constitutionally overturn the
election of the United States that was
the freest and most fairest election
that even Bill Barr said the idea that
something was stolen is absolutely
[ __ ] was his was his words um even
watching more tape from him today and a
former as a former government person I
can just tell you the fact of that
meeting Junior staffers escorting them
into the White House house and lighting
them in you can well understand why Pat
cipolloni and Powell's in in Sydney
Powell's words set a land speed record
it's holy [ __ ] what's happening that is
absolutely something the chief of staff
cannot permit to happen it shows Meadows
being either feckless or kind of in on
the on the whole um ruse or or
conspiracy so just that it starts that
way is one thing and then what
transpires thereafter six hours and just
a few minutes later he sends that big
tweet I found it a pretty persuasive
case that he had ignored all the
grown-ups gone with Team crazy and was
implementing their plan right away and
it was in fact accepted by the the
terrorists who came on the six as a call
to Arms he he meant it that way they
took it that way Well the lady was who
who kept saying release the Kraken we
know now Sydney Palace she was one of
the influencers and you know some of the
deposition tape of her
still in this mindset it just it's a
it's it's amazing to me that here we are
she's sitting before the select
committee
um being deposed about the election
being overturned by the president where
she was giving this this delusional
advice this delusional constitutional
advice I guess you'd call it and here
she is still in this mindset
um sipping a Dr Pepper and yeah having a
good arrogant uh disparaging of all the
real officials again people like that
exist in the world that they exercise
the power and will of the present that's
crazy
um I don't know how much time you have
Tony but can I tell you one other big
Revelation today go ahead yeah please
okay so so fine they you know he pushes
and gets Pence mentioned in there that's
already scandalous but I I was
um really struck that then he goes to
the rally and ad-libs and what's the
ad-lib seven mentions of Pence to get
them revved up about this you know
nothing about the peacefully the line
that was inserted in there to give him
deniability everything he does is really
and truly intended to rev them up into a
murderous intense rage that they would
have torn the vice president Lim from
limb and I think we're going to find out
of this final hearing as all of this is
you know as DC is burning he he is
laughing he won't you know he won't put
out a tweet and when he finally does he
says go home we love you you know this
is this is really a deluded kind of you
know complete takeover by the by by
domestic terrorists except again it's
abetted by the president of the United
States domestic terrorists are out there
they don't get to do the bidding of the
president well I appreciate you pointing
that fact out as well Harry Littman
please please plug your your podcast as
we sit here oh well that's very Connie
it's so talking feds uh which uh I we've
uh we we do week in week out with some
really great guests Jamie Raskin often
among them but you know we're really
proud of the sort of Round Table I think
you'd only see people like that on sort
of Sunday shows and even then it would
be for sound bites these are sort of
pretty rich discussions so thanks a lot
Tony for serving it up no problem and
and also subscribe to the mighty statue
Network where Harry appears yeah uh in
in great videos in his reflection for
them yeah in his great crystal ball of
knowing that Cassidy Hutchison reactions
and predictions all right that's right
thank you very much Harry thanks for
joining us all right see you Tony
welcome back to the show thank you for
joining us we have a reoccurring guest
I'm super excited to ask him about his
response to the Jason Van Tatton Hove I
believe is how you say his name the
former oath keeper
um I I view him kind of as a
propagandist I don't know if he said
exactly that
um but I I do view him as The Oath
Keepers propagandist he was actually
named propaganda and then he kind of
went under a different name to continue
that I want to welcome Dakota Von Adams
Dakota welcome welcome welcome to the
podcast again uh last week we talked
about some of the militia movement and
how the right wing on the internet uses
groups like 4chan and stuff to dilute
the minds of some of these young people
but today we're here to talk about
the response that you have from the
testimony of Jason Van tatenhove and the
January 6th select hearing
but I think it's kind of the same thing
isn't it where
Jason kind of says hey these people are
being brainwashed kind of like what we
were talking last week is it it did I
get that sense right yes but especially
in a
in online messaging and in the priming
people to commit violence
when the when the call up happens now
Jace uh Jason's position I believe he
does call himself a propagandist in some
prior interviews and so that's entirely
Fair as a label and uh Jason
was basically single-handedly
responsible for the most successful of
The Oath Keepers
um
digital
imprint and their digit and their
internet impact after the era of blog
spot
where they were highly successful all
more recent Oath Keepers success in
online messaging uh Jason had a hand in
that through when he separated with
oathkeepers and it's funny because he
would have at the time he got involved
with Oath Keepers and became their media
coordinator was basically the exact
moment that oh Hebrews began to take
that hard turn into being a militia
instead of the gradual transformation
that it had been leading up to Bondi
Ranch now your family has a lot of
history with Jason just because uh
Stewart Rhodes the founder of The Oath
Keepers you're a strange father
um lived with Jason but also had a very
kind of weird relationship but he had
weird relationships and throughout his
adult life Stu being Steward where he
would sleep on people's couches he would
kind of hermit with people in their
houses Jason didn't touch too much on
that
um but tell me a little bit about that
relationship that your family kind of
has with Jason and how you know Jason
and if you know him or have talked to
him tell us about what you know about
Jason yep so Jason uh after beginning to
work for Oath Keepers following those
standoffs that He covered before
becoming National media coordinator for
Oath Keepers um
Stewart was super enthusiastic about him
Jason was at the time this thing that
Stuart would do where he would have a
pedestal boy for a few months he'd have
a favorite person who could do no wrong
that was the newest brightest shiniest
person possible and he uh had Oath
Keepers moved Jason to our town here in
Eureka the grocery store that he talks
about where he overheard Oath Keepers
Associated people
uh talking Holocaust denial that is the
grocery store in town that I go to every
week so we moved him up here Oath
Keepers was paying the rent on his cabin
and continued paying the rent on it like
paying rent on his cabin for quite a
while I believe his moving fees were
covered Stewart headhunted him not only
for a position in Oath Keepers to be
part of Stewart's personal Inner Circle
for his tobacco Valley Eureka area
Community that he wanted around him
directly when the apocalypse happened
wow and that's where I got to know Jason
I I see and and of course Stewart
continues his relationship as uh Jason
had kind of separate and Steward had
separated from the family and you guys
had kind of broke apart so tell me what
you make of what Jason said do you think
Jason included the entire story and do
you think he was a very he was a good
character witness for America to
understand who Stuart is and who The
Oath Keepers are I think yes I think
because Jason is
uh
pretty good example of somebody who
probably was like as a as a Libertarian
was ready to be swept up politically in
Oath Keepers got involved with it just
to report on it and ended up getting
sucked in and then was along for the
ride for a good while after that I think
he is positioned very well to tell
people about what Oath Keepers is and
nothing that he said today was wrong
every single thing was correct that Oath
Keepers is Stewart they are a violent
militia their vision for America is
based on using deceit to enforce their
vision of the deceitan violence to
enforce their vision of the future
everything is about Stewart's ego as a
paramilitary leader in his own mind with
the thinnest of fictions that he's not a
militia General and propping himself up
only thing he didn't do was in Prior
interviews had
left off with the time that he
officially resigned from Oath Keepers in
2014 when he did keep working for Oath
Keepers anonymously as a as a
contributing writer and an associate
editor under a pen name through 2017 and
had Stuart living in his house after he
was no longer in our home
through to like late 2018 early 2019 and
continued to associate with them to the
extent of testifying for Stewart as a
character witness in our custody hearing
for the divorce case so he I feel by a
mission downplayed the extent of his
involvement with Stewart and how much
longer that went on
after the Holocaust and now conversation
that he talks about he might have been
trying to start the separation process
well before but he was still pretty
deeply embedded for years to come
so he was he was his relationship with
Stewart continued enough that he was
actually what's kind of um I guess
ironic is he in open court testified as
a character witness in support of
characters of Stewart's character here
um in open court or open Committee in
front of America he testified against
Stewart's character so it seems like a
really a big 180 flip
um within a few years of changing his
mind about Stuart which it seems to be a
pattern with Stuart so I guess it's
probably not surprising that even
someone like Jason Van tatnov who is
part of the libertarian movement as you
said you know the the Ron Paul Rand Paul
libertarian and we've talked about this
before how Stuart that's kind of how he
got his start he wrote that wave
right right he can't we talked about it
I think in the first interview where we
uh did the interview with you and your
mom we talked about that's how Stewart
kind of started this whole Oath Keepers
and that's how he kind of started this
this idea of what it would become and
and be so tell me about the dangers
because Jason
um laid out a very very dark picture for
America of what it's like if we don't
listen to what these right Wingers are
telling us that they want and that
they're going to do I felt like he was
kind of standing on the table saying Hey
listen to what the Republicans the GOP
and these right-wing militias and these
right Wingers and frankly some of these
neo-nazis are telling you that they want
to do these fascists are here it's not a
thing where you're where they're almost
here they are here they are never wrong
they're in government they're a voting
block their movement they're trying to
seize control of local government
positions that are on your school board
they're trying to shut down your library
they are trying to form a flash mobs to
attack drag shows they're doing all of
the [ __ ] and just like Oath Keepers the
pattern of behavior
that would lead to January 6 was long
established by those standoffs that went
largely unpunished and they largely
escaped consequences for
the the very standoffs that Jace that
first the coverage of which first Drew
Jason in and that is what we have to
look at is every single thing that goes
unanswered that a right-wing group does
then becomes rehearsal so what is
happening right now attacks on any event
that they don't like uh campaign ads
that
for congress Critters that essentially
call for Vigilante violence against
Traders within the Republican Party
and
and increasing openness in rejecting
democracy and American ideals as a
failed experiment in favor of
uh more totalitarian Christian
nationalism because that's what's just
what you got to do to get through the
hard times
well uh a dark picture that he painted
but one that I think America should pay
attention to especially with the
interviews that we've done with you and
some of the dark pictures you painted
of militia so there was another witness
there with him
um as kind of a a way to I don't know
maybe undermine this idea that that you
can you'll always be manga if you're
manga right because I I believe that you
have experienced that people join the
militia
um they maybe believe in the
quote-unquote militia movement whatever
that you know shiny object may be at
that exact time but they discover what
it's really about and and defect
so what did you make of where Jason
described his defectment but also the
other witness heirs uh his defect
defecting from Maga and the January 6
after he was in a violent insurrections
so uh Ayers is a classic example of
somebody truly being swept up in the
moment and swept up in the movement
where Jason's case was over the course
of years
um Ayers was swept up in a very short
time simply through being so thoroughly
plugged into the social media Echo
chamber that was feeding on itself and
it's I believe much sadder for his like
well for one thing Ayers had the
presence of mind to wear a suit instead
of his uh instead of his work jacket and
band shirt right right
um
but Ayers is just
I I don't say simple on any derogatory
sense because he seems like somebody who
intentionally lives a simple life
because living an uncomplicated life and
focusing on the things that are
important to him is what he wanted I get
like everybody knows Ayers you probably
everybody listening to this probably has
a couple of heirs in their immediate
circle of friends or acquaintances or
Associates he's just
a regular run-of-the-mill show who was
plugged into the energy of the Trump
campaign and Maga through social media
got super amps because he thought he was
being called to defend America
and was involved in a very serious crime
on behalf of Puppet Masters who
attempted to use him as a disposable
tool and he's only just realizing
that he's been used I found it very
interesting about heirs that he
described how it destroyed his life
um
have you seen that a lot in the militia
movement because Maga isn't exactly a
militia movement the militia movement
may be Maga but Maga isn't a militia
movement maybe it's a white supremacist
movement maybe you could probably
describe it that way it's a broad
spectrum with like like uh previously
the committee had been talking about uh
Department of Homeland Security analysis
that they were seeing Blended ideology
it's a broad spectrum
cultural conservative or at least
conservative coded Blended ideology that
is designed to fit in everyone that
could potentially do violence or simply
mobilize as a voting block on behalf of
conservative control of the country with
its figurehead as Donald Trump and
militia movements like I talked about in
my op-ed a little bit ago
the militias generally made a decision
to align themselves with Maga because
they saw it as a shake-up of the status
quo or potential to hold off the
collapse and give them more time or
prevent it entirely or simply as a
business decision because aligning with
Maga was the path of least resistance
for continuing to stay relevant
after the Trump election and continue to
make money
so you mentioned your op-ed in Raw Story
which everyone should go take a look at
um and thank you for that piece of work
and I hope we we hear more from you uh
in written articles not just video form
but also written form I'm going to do
them shorter from here on out okay well
great well it is a very long one but
it's a great piece everyone should go
read it it's a raw story I'll put the
link here so everyone can find it
appreciate that yeah no problem what I
do want to ask you though is pinning it
all together because I know that was
something that the committee was trying
to do so from the perspective of the
committee do you think they use Jason
and even heirs in a way
that can kind of untangle some of this
web for some of these Americans that may
believe some of this stuff maybe leave
the big lie or maybe not believe it just
it feels good to be on that side do you
think that the committee did a good job
at using their testimony to tell part of
that story or do you think it could have
been better worse what's your opinion on
the kind of things that you did a pretty
excellent job I think Ayers
um very clearly uh is a case study in
the average Joe who was swept up in the
day of the Insurrection the guys who
showed up for the million manga march to
support the president and then were
peeled off
into a riot targeted aimed at the
capital it was a perfect representation
of the average Joe who got sucked in
through his social media consumption and
was used as a patsy in a crime next to
him they have Jason who is a very good
case study and characterization of
somebody who was sucked into the militia
movement and in and was there for the
previous standoffs who also
testifies very strongly about what the
militia always was
and what these groups are like so that
later on when I believe the link is
going to be drawn
more firmly and in the work that the
community has already done between
showing uh Trump and his allies
intentionally inciting
the Insurrection that on the side that
Ayers was a part of the mob mobilization
of people that are used and also in
knowingly
um
utilizing and getting in bed with these
militias on the other side
like they knew that they demonstrate
once they demonstrate the links the
viewer will understand that the Trump
White House and the Republican Party
knew exactly what they were doing with
that with this multi-pronged strategy
bring in bodies use them to create chaos
have these militias who you understand
exactly what they are ready to execute a
mission under the cover of it
now I do understand that the committee
speaking of the committee they actually
left out some of the uh script as it
were or some of the content that they
wanted to show the country because they
had the testimony of Pat cipolloni so I
I actually think there was some content
um and evidence that they wanted to show
the country they just did not do that
because of timing
um so maybe we'll get to see that in
later hearings maybe we won't I'm not
really sure but I guess my question
would be this because not only did we
see the committee maybe lack the some of
the evidence that they were going to
show but we also watched this drama
of the founder of The Oath Keepers
Stuart Rhodes in the last week go from
[ __ ] the committee to hey I want to come
testify again please let me testify
because he's kind of he's done a lot of
different positions here right when he
first was detained for the charges
um claiming full cooperation right and
and then he went and he actually did
testify in front of the committee so
maybe that's some of the the testimony
that we didn't get to see I I'm not
really sure I'm interested in seeing
that one and eventually it is used and
I'm interested in seeing why they've
held it back for this particular episode
where they are also utilizing an oath
Keeper's witness right I I think that's
interesting and I don't know if it's
because of the pat cipolloni testimony
they felt it was more relevant and
important towards the thrust of hey
Donald Trump was behind this all it
wasn't exactly Stuart Road Stewart
Rhodes was kind of a you know a pawn in
the in Trump's game right yeah he wasn't
subordinate yes right exactly because
it's seems to be and we've talked about
this before that Stuart Rhodes was
waiting on an order from I don't know
someone you know from the White House
that would be able to declare martial
law or the Insurrection somebody whose
name reminds you of rocks right that's
probably who it would be right well and
and that's the go-between is what you're
saying I believe that too because of uh
the the the the switch from the proud
boys to The Oath Keepers and then
Stewart having the orders over the qrf
the stash of weapons we've talked about
this before but the most interesting
thing that I found the last week in the
Stuart Road Saga part of this is that
Stewart not only wanted to now testify
but he had conditions kind of like Steve
Bannon right it almost felt like Steve
Bannon and Stewart's little Saga here
that they wanted to go before the
committee this unselect ridiculous you
know unconstitutional committee if they
really believed all that why would they
now want to participate but I found it
funny that it was almost a coordinated
effort seemed to be that they wanted to
not only testify under oath but they
wanted to be live they wanted to be
unedited they could say anything they
want now my belief is that Stewart was
trying to torch the criminal prosecution
that the doj has on him but give me your
take because it doesn't seem like the
committee is going to participate in a
live hot mic opportunity for Stuart
Rhodes to blast whatever he wants to
blast or Steve Bannon either one really
um it does Two of a Kind really well you
know one has an eye patch one has a gab
but that really they both have scabs
well that's true
um
but I guess I guess the point here is
that the committee has seemed to tell
them to basically [ __ ] off that you you
had your chance we we interviewed you we
have the evidence against you but what
is your take on Stewart specifically of
why he would want to now do this now
that the committee has come out with all
this evidence and basically it's damning
against him and his allies uh like uh
Roger Stone Steve Bannon Mike Flynn all
the Oath Keepers the proud boys what do
you think now Stewart's decided that he
wants to go in front of a hot mic in
front of America to tell his story is it
because he wants to be famous or does he
actually want to tell the truth
he absolutely doesn't want to just tell
the truth he wants to tell the story of
his ego now
possibly
I know that some people were probably
aware of Tatton Hove testifying before
it went fully public uh I think Stewart
is very much afraid of Tatton hoe's
testimony because Tatton Hove was with
him through a lot of radical [ __ ] and I
think they also had a probably called
very close personal relationship because
I'm just going to this is basically
public knowledge in Eureka
as it is now because I keep hearing
about it from people years after the
fact but uh tattenhove and his wife were
very active in the swinger community
and I believe that is why one of the
reasons why Stuart uh
wanted to move them up because there
have been multiple occasions where there
were couples that I'm pretty sure were
swinger couples that were also in the
prepper movement that Stuart very
specifically wanted to live near us or
on the property in a kind of a compound
situation this is a pattern or occurring
pattern of behavior because Stewart
essentially wants to be Doc antol for
anyone who's seen Tiger King and but us
a survivalist version where we also
Lords over all the husbands as their
military commander uh so they're not
just tiger Wrangler but uh uh uh warlord
kind of thing yeah Stewart wants to be
uh
uh uh the war of the warlord of a
post-apocalyptic policy is essentially
what it boils down to and
I think that element of it is probably
something like if Jason didn't hasn't
talked about it already he might not I
know that
he means highly fair to Jason in the
time since I'm about since I brought
this up in the time that he Stuart was
living with him he had also broken his
leg uh trying to cut firewood is that
why he has the cane is that the reason
why yes I think that is a lingering
effect from that injury broke his leg
very badly he had been working as a fire
line EMT for large Wildfire incidents so
his main non-othkeepers income stream
was cut off he's injured he's
uh parenting his family with his
disabled wife who has chronic health
problems very vulnerable position to be
in while your boss is living with you
right so it's why I'm not as angry with
him as I would otherwise be especially
about the custody uh testimony part the
so but I think that plays into how
afraid Stewart would be uh Jason's
testimony because there's probably some
non-oath keeper or militia related
things that strictly that Jason would be
able to say that would crush stewards
um platform in the movement
more thoroughly than just him being a
radical because that's a good thing in
the eyes of his base and while he
Stewart is motivated by fear of Jason's
testimony about his radical [ __ ] and
possibly their personal relationship
while he was living with them Stewart is
going to take the opportunity to
grandstand because Stewart is in all or
nothing at this point he believes either
he's going to die in prison or in my
opinion
really believe that at the 11th Hour
Trump is going to return to power or
future president the scientists will
pardon him or he's just going to get
acquitted and beat the rap because he's
that good and his attempt to appear
before the committee live unedited Ron
wriggling in the same building as the
committee
was an attempt to rant them attack their
legitimacy grandstand before America and
attempt to build a platform for when he
gets out and resumes being the general
of Oath Keepers right so it sounds like
some of the stuff that we've talked
before where with the Bundy Ranch thing
um Stewart really believes he may break
the rap and I believe there's evidence
in that where he would did a jailhouse
interview with Dinesh D'Souza of all
this craziness
um you know Stuart Rhodes doing an
interview with Dinesh D'Souza doesn't
really give the select committee any
reason to take Stuart Road seriously at
this point no matter what he would say
the conditions are and rather he would
be under oath or not I think that's the
case there
um I and you know better than most of
how seriously you can take Stuart
um do you do you think do you think
there is any chance that Hell Freezes
Over or that Stewart actually sits and
in front of a live microphone with the
select committee what do you think
I think it's extremely unlikely because
his main reason for testifying would be
to make the committee into a circus with
himself as the main clown that's it
that's the that's the be-all end-all of
any testimony that he would give to the
committee
live and I think they know that and know
that's not going to be valuable and will
only be used as Clips on as a clip show
for Stephen Crowder and Dinesh D'Souza
and all the other Bottom Feeders to
further Galvanize his base
right so it's a it's more of a a press a
press run for Stewart in the future to
come when when Maga King Trump becomes
king and pardons him yes he wants to
establish his big Hollywood moment of
speaking his truth to all of those
corrupt politicians sitting up there
above them and rail against them on
behalf of the real American people and
he's effectively it's resume building
well you know for the future if Stewart
ever sees the light of day
um again maybe he can start a truth
Social account and be over there where
all the truthful stuff that really is
you know
social is no matter how short Stuart
stint in prison is
um it will most likely outlive truth
social
well I I appreciate I always appreciate
your your commentary here but also your
Insight uh deep inside not just the
militia movement but uh Stuart Rhodes is
mine I know
um you didn't choose to be
um tied to Stewart like this you just
are there's just the nature of it so I
didn't uh I didn't choose this life it
shows me that's right that's right and
we appreciate you coming here and uh
speaking out and and your op-eds so tell
us a little more about the op-ed before
you go where people can find it what
it's about and what to what to expect
more of from Dakota Von Adams
um tell them what to expect here if we
can find more work from you tell us
about that op-ed all right so it's a
piece I've been putting off writing for
a long time mostly out of imposter
syndrome and the belief that I'm
probably just not a very good writer and
but it's one that I have needed to write
and I was contacted by Raw Story and
went you know gonna have to do that so
it is effectively the story of
the initial militia movement and Patriot
movement programming that I received
through my childhood and through my
adolescence and teen years with Oath
Keepers and then the series of shocks to
my belief system
that started to undermine
my mental conditioning
until eventually I realized that
everything was fake and I
what it effectively is is my best
attempt at showing you what the inside
of someone's head is like while they're
fully wrapped up in something like Maga
or the Patriot movement or a militia
cause because I was and what the inside
of their head looks like when they begin
to doubt and what it takes for them to
begin to doubt
and done my absolute best to
take you on a guided tour through my
deprogramming journey in a way that is
hopefully valuable to people that have
lost friends and families and Associates
and Neighbors
to right-wing cult gravity
well we appreciate your work in that uh
in that area and I think if you just
probably Google Rawl story Dakota Adams
or Dakota Von Adams you will or Dakota
or Dakota Rhodes it's got my previous
name and the title and any previous any
future things that I write I'm going to
include uh Dakota Rhodes or Dakota
Stewart Rhodes somewhere very large and
keyword searchable so that it's brought
up and in the future I'm working on two
pieces right now one I've already told
you the bullet points of my experience
at the uh gun show that had a dividing
wall down the middle of the convention
center with an anime convention and my
realization that the militia crowd are
just the least fun
basket of weird nerds out of many weird
nerd fandoms and then a longer and more
serious piece not as long as this op-ed
which is a excessive but uh longer more
serious piece about specifically my
brush with uh Stormfront and other white
supremacist groups attempting to recruit
on 4chan and how ironically all of my
conditioning does cease Sinister
conspiracies in every shadow in my
childhood allowed me to clock the right
wing pipeline for what it was instantly
well I appreciate you coming on and
everyone go go follow Dakota on on
Twitter at Dakota V Adams I got that
right right and it's at the bottom of
the screen there go follow the code on
Twitter he'll be posting those stories
he'll be yeah there you go there you go
great advertising great averages
eventually inaugurating a sub stack like
all the other crazy people great great
that hey I I love to hear that you're
going to start a sub stack and we can
maybe on a weekly basis hear what you
have to say and I'll tell you absolutely
please come everyone can go to our
YouTube channel and um see a playlist of
the times that Dakota has come on and
talked about The Oath Keepers uh and the
proud boys even
um but keep coming on if we see some of
this video from Stuart out of this
select hearing I'd love to hear you uh
what you have to say so come back Dakota
my friend uh have a good day I
appreciate you coming back on uh thank
you for continuing to inflict yourself
upon me and your viewers oh well the
viewers love you the audience loves you
they think you're brilliant so thank you
thank you Dakota we'll talk to you soon
my friend
take care
you've been listening to the Tony
Michaels podcast in your face commentary
of current events and political news no
rules No Boundaries I think we've made
that perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed
the show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow Tony on social media at
the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] em [ __ ] em
[Music]
foreign
[Music]